il y a un an je vous interrogeait déjà
sur les projets de fermetures de classes
dans les communes rurales de notre pays
aujourd'hui la situation qui s'annonce
est encore pire
vos promesses se sont envolés des
dizaines de classes vont encore fermées
et la france périphérique se sent plus
que jamais abandonné en seine-et-marne
en annonce près de 180 fermetures
touchent en plus de 150 communes sur 507
contre moins d'un tiers d'ouverture les
habitants sont exaspérés les élus locaux
sont désespérés nos villes et nos
villages ne pourront pas faire face
monsieur le ministre en fermant ses
classes quel avenir réservé vous au
monde rural la parole pour vous répondre
et au secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'éducation nationale de la
jeunesse
je suis gamin laquelle vous avez la
parole merci à monsieur le président
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice chien
larcher je vous prie d'excuser
effectivement jean michel blanquer
requis et à l'assemblée nationale pour
l'examen d'une proposition de loi sur
l'école inclusive vous posez la question
de l'école et dans la ruralité qui est
un sujet un sujet sensible parce qu'il
renvoie à la question de la présence des
services publics dans nos territoires et
dans nos territoires ruraux en
particulier sur ce sujet je veux
rappeler l'effort colossal budgétaire
qui a été déployée par le gouvernement
depuis deux ans pour renforcer la
présence colère dans la ruralité vous
prenez les 45 départements les plus
ruraux en 2017 et 2018
ces quarante mille élèves en moins et
pourtant 400 postes créés en plus la
démographie aurait dû conduire
mathématiquement lefa statistiquement
comme c'est prévu selon les règles à la
suppression de postes la suppression de
casques de classe c des postes
supplémentaires qui ont été créés ça va
se poursuivre en 2010 neuf puisque on
attend encore une baisse démographique
et que au national de 1235 postes seront
créés dans votre département de
seine-et-marne
ces 700 élèves en moins qui sont
attendus à la rentrée 2010 9 ce sera 40
professeurs en plus qui arriveront en
seine et marne à la rentrée 2010 9
c'est donc un effort important je veux
insister sur le fait que le président de
la république s'est engagé lors de la
conférence nationale des territoires à
ce qu'il y ait une vigilance accrue des
services académiques sur la question des
fermetures de classes et plus gravement
encore sur la question des fermetures
d'écoles dans la ruralité parce que
c'est un sujet qui peut se présenter si
à une baisse drastique de la démographie
si on veut maintenir un niveau de
qualité éducative importance et des
sujets qui peuvent se poser
ils doivent toujours se poser en lien
avec les élus locaux évidemment avec les
parlementaires du territoire c'est la
consigne est donnée aux services
académiques
je rappelle par ailleurs que à ce stade
fait référence à la rentrée prochaine
toutes les fermetures ouvertures de
classes qui sont annoncés au prévus sont
conditionnelles rien n'a été acté rien
n'est acté c'est bien les inscriptions
constater les anticipations constater
qu'ils décideront bien plus tard dans
l'année des ouvertures et fermetures de
classes je veux aussi rappeler que nous
avons déployés dans la nuit deux
conventions ruralité une dizaine en 2018
grâce notamment à l'implication du
sénateur alain durand votre collègue et
qu'une mission est en cours avec madame
azéma et monsieur macho pour travailler
sur la question de l'éducation et des
territoires et notamment de la ruralité
nous aurons ces retours dans les
prochaines semaines et sans doute
sera-t-il des adaptations à prévoir au
niveau national je vous remercie madame
aicha larcher monsieur le ministre
des adaptations nous les attendons
effectivement parce que l'art et rallie
la réalité je vais vous la dire c'est
dans un même regroupement pédagogique de
fermeture en deux ans coup sur coup
comment voulez vous que les maires face
vous nous parler chiffres choix
perspective est fort mais qui fait des
efforts nous vous parlons d'enfants qui
sont nos adultes de demain dont le seul
tort est de vivre à la campagne mais
aussi d' équipe d'enseignants qui font
un travail remarquable et qui ont besoin
de stabilité de villes et de villages
dont le dynamisme va être anéanti des
territoires qui souffrent et que vous
refuser d'entendre après les entreprises
les commerces les médecins maintenant
les écoles mais ces français que vous
voyez comme ceux qui ne sont rien et
ceux qui roulent au diesel et fument des
clopes
eux aussi sont la france vous leur
promettez un grand débat et en même
temps vous ne leur laissait aucune
chance
tout cela n'est qu'enfumage vous
organisez la france des clivages vous ne
répare et pas la france comme cela
bien